just when you think you know how the
script is going to go it changes
thrilled to have you with us Curtis
Granderson jrro the Hall of Famer Pedro
Martinez my name is Lauren shti we left
our feet on that final you guys were as
calm as can be Bases Loaded one out
wouldn't all of you say collectively
seeing catel Marte on Deck that's who
you want up there that that's the guy
that I mean Pomo we were like if he gets
it done cool but if he gets on base and
marte's up there it's over and it was we
talking about the lineup change at the
beginning of the uh or for the for the
uh opener um that's why it was done
Carol has been struggling Marte has been
on fire he was the right man in the
right spot great job by Tor making that
move he took a for seamer down the
middle the first picture we're going oh
that was the opportunity made up for it
but sometimes you just got to get your
timing right and to get your emotions
like Lauren you over here dancing and
running around I am not made for the not
scribbling scrabbling and then you're
asking okay are you nervous in that
situation maybe kle need needed just one
to get himself right where he needed to
be and that's all he needed I said Pedro
I was interviewing Pedro in the
commercial break I said I said are you
nervous no way if you're Craig Kimbrell
in that moment what are you trying to do
Bas has loaded one out oh basically
you're trying to get as many outs as
possible some probably a pop up or maybe
strike out but uh it didn't happen uh I
I didn't kind of like precisely Kimbro
in a nons safe situation okay uh and you
said that right when I brought him in
yeah said I said it because I I've seen
him enough where I know that if it's to
close the game Kimbro might be one of
the best guys you have but when it's
non-safe situation he he just throws too
many balls he knebles around too much he
can get himself in trouble and that's
exactly what happen you know I was
watching GLE and Jose Alvarado and you
know starter set the tone but in October
bolt guys and Bullpen guys can be your
life flood and we saw that in this game
and it has been that way I mean the
whole postseason for the Phillies but
today was just a little bit different
and and although I mean we're talking a
little bit different cuz they gave up
one run and then Kimbrell obviously at
the end that's how dominant the bull
pens and been but the starters we talked
about it yeah keep yourself in the ball
game do not let Philly jump out in the
lead and uh F did that uh spares did
that for the other side but it was a
well played game got themselves in a
situation they needed instant classic
how much do you practice base running
because that was big we were watching
the ninth inning together and you guys
were saying pav Smith truth Curtis how
much they practice today C now you're
practicing b r now it's changed a lot I
mean you'd get the spring training and
you'd have a full day of just base
running then during batting practice
you'd have your base running sliding
practice sliding practice you'd even
come out early for base running it's
been a while since you see that now the
Diamondbacks go by the book and try to
do as much stuff as they can to go ahead
and continue the baseball fundamentals
of it but a lot of that stuff has been
lost because again we haven't valued the
stolen base as much we haven't valued
the extra B as much but when you see if
you can get someone in position and you
can put pressure on the defense at this
time of the year that's when it matters
that's when you want to have base
running be your key fundamental but you
can't work on it in October it has to be
worked on in February to get yourself
ready for these situations oh my
goodness Arizona has some chances bottom
of the seventh double play bottom of the
eighth as well would you we to lello
came in saying we need to play
Diamondbacks baseball I don't really
think it was Diamondbacks baseball like
we saw in the division series but they
manufactured runs but it was yet still
diamond backs baseball they kept putting
pressure pressure and and and forcing
things to happen Phillies were making
great plays had the infield end had the
ball hit the tray a double play that no
one expected but yes we're used to
seeing them you know put pressure on
teams and and three four five six run
Innings that's not happening this time
of year pitching is still at a premium
but they did what they needed to do make
them make plays take pitches have good
at bats they got themselves some walks
there when Marte came up he was like
it's time to go home boys and there was
also two situations too wasn't a stolen
base wasn't the base running getting a
runner over they had runner at second
base and they got him over in two
situations to do what Jimmy said put
pressure on when you get a runner out
there one more base 90 ft closer really
puts more pressure on the pitcher and on
the defense and what you're going to
call behind the plate as a catcher it's
so interesting it feels like a different
game when Brandon fought started this
game and Ranger Suarez it was like a
walk in the park for Ranger Wars you
couldn't get in a rhythm against him ice
cold I mean you said it in the prame
yeah Cold Blood a killer I I love rer I
think he has the best presence I I've
ever seen for someone pitching in a big
game uh I have to also give credit to
lulo by taking Tommy Tommy fan out of
first and and bringing and bring and
bringing Thomas to run the bases that
was one big key for him but he dodged a
bullet as much as I say he dodg a bullet
uh I have to give him credit for that
and then making the right the Right
Moves when he needed to with his relever
you mean taking Brandon fought out in
the six is that what you yeah that's
where he dodged a bullet right because
the kid did not have any struggles in
any of the innings did not sweat to get
those guys out and as he was going he
was getting even better to pull him out
in that situation could have easily
backfired but I'm glad it didn't and I
wasn't I'm I wasn't happy with it Tori
and and I'm not happy with it but ited
out but it worked out for him can we get
Pedro's reaction when they when when
they P out scream from other room but
are you damned if you do and damned if
KY warber Clips you third time to
through live with it live with it
because he had gone through 18 batters
with nine strikeouts and only two hits
if that one gets me we're still in the
game right now that's one of those solo
shots that the Phillies have been
hitting and Pedro I saw the question pop
up on there what would you have said the
manag com managers coming up to you to
take the ball out of your hand in that
situation I'm glad I'm not I'm not a
player from this era because I would to
tell the manager hey no no no no and
even when he got to the Mount we were
going to have a discussion or he was
going to have to ask me if I went out of
that game because I was going to tell
him first of all I would tell him no no
no no no no no no I'll would let him
know that I don't want to come out and
then when he gets to the mound there was
another argument to get me out of the
mound why because I grew up in a
different ERA in baseball and we would
not known that if you didn't struggle
you were going to come out of the game
now it's different analytics Department
plays a big role in it I saw the
pitching coach later on having a
conversation with the kid rightfully saw
the kid had no other choice but to obey
what the manager and pitching coach
would probably tell him but they dodg a
big time bullet today because if that
backfires on Tor lulo uh I don't know
where he was going to hide himself from
all the questions he was going to get
and first SP walk and keep in mind Kevin
long was interviewed comp in the game
they asked him what's going on we have
not seen him you can see the first two
times around they still are not seeing
him so it doesn't matter the third time
around numbers if we've never seen
somebody and he's as dominant as he is
you got to continue to keep riding him
out there Tor lell said coming into this
game 18 batters was the plan for him
he's a rookie and they stuck to that
plan by the way I want no part of that
argument wait a minute it's a bad plan
it's a horrible plan
where where is your your experience as a
journeyman baseball uh coming into play
when are you saying yourself well my
eyes are telling me different I I went
for 18 but I won 22 he's dominating seen
this time and time again in the
postseason we' seen it in the World
Series yeah on the grandest stage so
it's analytics vers
feel F the snail the snail situation
comes into play Rich heill situation
comes into play we we have many
bad memories about pulling guys out
burials this year burials pulled out I
mean all of those things could have
easily backfired I'm glad it didn't
because I love Tor lulo and Brent
strump but but it could have easily
backfire and put them in a real bad
position all around baseball